well james t kirk will be happy to know
i am currently taking the Kobayashi Maru
test the no-win scenario is reviewing
this movie that's right whatever side
you fall on with ghostbusters you're
going to piss off one half of the
Internet as a man who has accepted that
fact let's review it
ghostbusters so ghostbusters is a remake
of ghostbusters this time all-female
cast this one stars Melissa McCarthy
Kristen Wiig Leslie Jones and Kate
McKinnon as the four Ghostbusters with
Chris Hemsworth aka Thor as their
unusually stupid receptionist and Alice
busting ghosts eisah let's be honest
about it the trailer campaign leading up
to this movie it was horrible it sucked
this movie looked like a bag of and
now that I've seen the movie the movies
not as bad as it looks like it was and
yet it's not as good as you might want
it to be there were some good things in
this movie for sure this movie had me
chuckling quite often throughout the
movie which is a lot more than I thought
it was gonna do I never belly laughed in
the movie I wanted to build oh dude I'm
a grown-ass man I've seen a lot of
comedies out there make me belly laugh
didn't do it but the movie made me
consistently chuckle because this film
has quippy snappy dialogue has
pop-culture references other movie
references I'm a sucker for movie
references what can I say
standouts in this movie were Leslie
Jones and Kate McKinnon funny because
Kristen Wiig and Melissa McCarthy are
the biggest names in this movie but note
those two contributed the most of this
movie I thought that had the best lines
I thought they had the best delivery I
felt they added the most of this movie
however this movie has the misfortune of
calling itself ghostbusters I feel like
you could have tweaked the premise a
little bit and made a movie that pays
homage to ghostbusters but made it their
own thing but they decided to make it
ghostbusters in that this movie's going
to be compared to the original and it
does noting that the original does
Brenda the original Ghostbusters came
out when the concept of Ghostbusters was
bafflingly brand new it was
groundbreaking really nothing in
Hollywood's going to be groundbreaking
these days especially if you're making a
remake of something that came out in the
80s and you shouldn't always compare the
remake to the original the remake should
stand on its own you shouldn't have to
compare to the original maybe it's
unfair to compare it to the original you
know what I'm a human being and I can't
help but compare to the original in my
head I'm secret's out I'm just a human
being don't know if it's a character
flaw it might be but it happened a quick
examples evade the villain in this movie
he really did nothing for me there was
nothing about the villain that made me
think oh my gosh that's relevant he's
bad news I mean he was a little
for sure and bad things gonna go down
the stakes are high by the end of this
movie but in the original Dana Barrett
was dating one of the ghostbusters she
got possessed and so now the bringing on
of the main villain and the apocalypse
is tied to a romantic
interest among the Ghostbusters and that
makes it personal that gives it gravity
gives it weight this one is just kind of
somebody that's what I mean by you can't
help but compare to the original and how
the original just did that premise
better and Chris Hemsworth's comic
relieved the first couple times you're
like oh he's dumb and he did a dumb
thing by the end of this movie you're
like how many times you're gonna beat it
over our heads that Chris Hemsworth is
dumb and does dumb
yeah his character he's not bright we
get it made it a bit awkward when they
beat the same joke over your head a
hundred times and as much as this movie
wants to stand on its own as its own
film it has so many throw backs and
Easter eggs to the original you can't
help but be like are you standing on
your own are you riding the coattails of
the original kind of reminds me of
someone who tells off their parents like
you know what I'm moving out I'm
independent I'm strong I can make it on
my own
can I borrow 20 bucks oh okay
bit of a mixed signal but sure and the
pacing in this movie at a point I was
like this movie is a bit boring and I
say that because they bust one ghost in
the entire thing until the end I mean
the end climax in the trailer you see
all the ghosts and all that craziness
yeah they do their fair share of kick
and ass there one scene in particular
kate mckinnon steals the show and
everyone in the audience clap and i
wanted to do because that was actually a
pretty kick-ass scene good job but
leading up to that they bust one ghost
granted that's pretty much what they do
in the original Ghostbusters but the
original Ghostbusters although they
montage through all the ghost busting
the movie set up an atmosphere that
makes you feel like these guys are
getting done they're taking care of
business they're busting ghosts in their
town this one one goes until the very
end so in the lack of ghost busting in
this Ghostbusters this Ghostbusters
relies on the quippy dialogue to carry
the movie through in the end this
Ghostbusters movie is not as bad as some
people want it to be and it's not as
good as some people want it to be it
just kind of is and that's where this
movie falls it's not hot not cold has
some enjoyment but in the end is
lukewarm but for a Ghostbusters movie I
could have gotten for some better pacing
a better villain and some more ghost
busting this is me telling you I cannot
look you boldface and say hey go out and
see it right now pay full price in 3d so
I will say ghostbusters would probably
be a better time if it had better pacing
and you were drunk yeah now it's a party
Danton tattooed intent is a good beat
though like that song it's true this
movie does have a good mix of the
original Ghostbuster song is the one in
the trailer I just like that beat and
the end credits when that songs over
goes into that
horrible one that no one wants to listen
to but the first that was a good beat
alright so the new Ghostbusters have you
seen it what did you think about it was
it as good as you wanted it to be was it
as bad as you wanted it to be whatever
you think whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more